that's stranding I've heard of this I
don't know what this is but I've heard
of this it really interested well you
know I brought you here Alyssa to be hi
guys I'm Greg this is Alyssa oh hello I
didn't know we were filming it hi and uh
I brought you here you know to be the
girl who actually does gaming the girl
who's into games and it's weird that I
feel like I kind of know a little bit of
backstory about this game are you there
I've been keeping myself in the dark
because until I see a trailer I don't
like to know about it because I want it
to be like the first impression is like
either amazing like yeah you know what I
mean right with that being said great
justification as to why you don't know
much about this game I haven't seen the
trailer for it yet so yeah this game is
created by Hideo Kojima this is his
first game since he departed from the
Metal Gear franchise yeah and it has
Norman Reedus in it from The Walking
Dead wait they still did there was they
worked on Silent Hill together huh they
worked on Sun tell you guys wikipedia
has a ton of information here's the
thing that they were just like hell and
it did come out but now they know
Maria's back with Hiroshima
I'm still so mad about that because PT
the playable trailer for the silent
hill's game that was going to come out
was released and they teased it for fact
the most the scariest most terrifying
game I have ever played hands down and
it was just the trailer so the fact that
it didn't even come out is still like
stop my heart oh wow yeah no so what no
I wanted to play it so bad near like No
a Konami I'm like well back to death
stranding for a second okay
glad you feel passionate about that
Alyssa I do very passionate one thing
I'll start on Wikipedia I figured what
better YouTube video like this is the
best insightful video to just pass along
Wikipedia information I don't know why
you guys want me anyway whether you
write about Wikipedia was how Hideo
Kojima was talking about there's a short
story that talked about how the first
weapon man created was a stick to keep
people out of distance or keep away from
bad things second weapon was a rope
to help you like you know a [ __ ] rope
is used were so that was a second weapon
and he compared the basic combat
fighting a combat play of games like
punching kicking and all that to like
that of a stick and he said he wants to
integrate and you kind of gameplay where
it's that of a rope because then when
Metal Gear first came out it was
categorized as an action game but now
it's categorized as a stealth game
because stealth game wasn't a thing then
that's right so he wants create a new
thing now
interesting boom information
wikipedia.org that's ranning I'm
actually I did I did I'm intrigued the
first trailer for this I came out in I
think was during it III yeah I saw that
one too actually I love that he's back
oh no it gets death stranding strip Oh
what oh wait I can't remember this one
the first river the baby
[Music]
that's key L Rho del Toro yeah right
they were like work on something again I
think they worked on silent health again
yeah that was gonna be their preparation
and it didn't do a thing
that is pretty funny actually that might
be why people wanted me to check out
this trade and know for sure that's
supposed to be hermanos work what are
you two excited
Oh GZ gross whoo I love it
it's like eerie sci-fi oh yeah oh man
told you yeah
I love that his face is so expressive
what whoa hey I think that's motion
capture yeah that's me should have
smoked remember anything I read yeah I
bet it even said it without his gear
perfect
that's creepy man is it really I am so
interested in this right now what the
[ __ ] babies ah they're very good at
keeping the story in the dark
whoa this feels like a horror game I
think it is I wasn't expecting that
it's like a horror sci-fi game I mean
that'sthat's like what they do
Oh music I mean I don't really view the
Metal Gear games horror sighs no I mean
apparently I don't hit like Jo Nell oh
that's amazing kind of music like
stranger things yeah yeah this is cool
sci-fi music man
Oh No
there's Norman Reedus
you
I did read about that way this mass
Nicolson it's pretty cool
what the hell is going oh [ __ ] he's like
connected to all them I love this
what just happened I don't know but it's
awesome
that's so creepy
Wow he's like really in the game
Buddhist you can see the [ __ ] on his
face
I was sweet Oh Norman Reedus Mads
Mikkelsen hell yeah this looks awesome
like okay so it's the thing that I
really appreciate is uh for the first
trailer that we saw during during a
three
yes very bag super like we didn't get
anything of the story it was basically
like this looks creepy and this looks
beautiful but what is it like it didn't
give any ugly as to what the game
actually was what the story was or
anything I feel you dog
this looks incredible you know why I
might play it you know I might why is
the very tha very maybe maybe played is
because um it's the first installment
and I feel like every game people want
me to play is the [ __ ] sequel meaning
I have to play a whole other game to get
this [ __ ] game yeah and I'm like I do
order several games but this is
brand-new and that's cool
that just the developers and the people
involved have got these people so jacked
up you could like it's more to me it's
more than one like the creators of Halo
did destiny Hideo Kojima was so known
for didn't he work on um [ __ ] the
Silent Hill game yeah that was a man
grandmother's Horace well was it haha
that was supposed to be their big
collaboration and yeah Konami they I
think they did screen capture with
motion capture with Norman Reedus and
Mads Mikkelsen yeah they did motion
tracking sweet and but guillermo del
toro the character is created in the
likeness oh yeah something it actually
bringing here well those horror i think
but they did a very good job yeah cuz i
was like this that that has to be
caramel del toro yeah this looks like a
very defined sci-fi film
yes you know like what my experience of
Hideo Kojima games they don't feel
specifically science fiction like
post-apocalyptic kind of vine that
sounds really cool no the music they
have for it that sounds great
technically metal gear is science
fiction so I would love to see like
something that is very more specific
towards it Kojima tends to create like
the feel of his games and the backstory
like everything he's such a good
storyteller and whatever creates is
completely unique to him and that makes
a unique experience to the players and
the viewers yeah and it's not you know a
copy and paste oh this is a sequel oh
this is you know another platformer or
no anything like that what have you it's
they take so long to create the games
but at the same time they're so
beautiful it's so well done
you don't really mind that they take so
long to make because they are something
completely new I feel like he's always
aiming to make a different experience
for you it's not in the sense of like
when he would do sequels of like let's
just give them what they like in a few
more cool things you know it's like he's
always trying to he's always trying to
take it in another direction and give
you surprises well yeah I mean there's
no Norman Reedus in that but Norman Rius
and Mads Mikkelsen that's gonna be cool
and they have a scene together and it's
really great I've seen a lot of trailers
for games where they have like actors in
them but this looks like whoa there
really are gonna I get actually look
it's it looks more than great game
graphics it's not even game graphics
it's you don't look at them it's like oh
that's Norman Reedus it's like no this
is whatever that character is and he's
freaking amazing yeah doesn't give a
full performance alright good rejects
you're near the shower subscriber day
become a reject
I mean accepted that's cry Alyssa be
crazy follow her on Twitch
yes live streams Monday through Friday
at 4 p.m. Saturday 8 p.m. this guy will
be there getting drunk playing The Last
of Us
oh my god God yeah I didn't which Alyssa
be crazy I'll be there you be square if
you're not there peeing your underwear
so share this information if you
care do you dare not